hello
hey how's it going Pearl I'm good how
are you
good just saw your live stream thought
I'd call in
okay um so what do you think is the
solution for men and for women moving
forward because I've had a lot of
solutions for men so why don't why don't
you give me one for both
so this is actually a funny thing for me
I became a Mormon about 10 years ago
right when like
Tinder was uh just starting up and
becoming a thing okay and when I started
watching your show I saw like how
completely different the dating field is
nowadays but I think probably the
biggest thing right now is that there's
no maturity around dating like people
are just dating to have fun guys are
dating to have fun and get as many girls
as they want people aren't dating for
the purpose of marrying and having kids
anymore and and like the LDS Community
that's what we do when we date we date
because we're looking for somebody to
marry instead of somebody to just have
fun around with so it's it's crazy how
much the mentality of dating has just
completely changed in the last 10 years
because guys between girls nowadays they
get married when they're running out of
time and they're running out of options
so what what is the solution to you
moving forward dating with intention
and dating with intention but there's
got to be like a cultural shift like
everyone is viewed families not being
worth anything you know like family's
something that you do after you've had
fun instead of you start your life with
the intentions of having a family so
unless people actually have a reason to
get married there's no point you know if
you're just marrying so that way you
don't want to grow old and lonely that's
it's a pretty sad way to enter marriage
but if you're getting married with the
intention of having a family
you're dating different people than if
you're just looking for somebody to have
fun with so say say we're dating with
the intention of having a family
um do you think men should sign the
marriage contract
100 okay why
uh because when you sign a contract with
men and women when you enter into that
marriage Arrangement you're saying hey
we're going to be together
thicker thin no matter what happens
we're together for the purpose of having
kids raising a family growing all
together and dying together that's what
your intention is when you get married
unfortunately divorce has become so easy
people get married I don't even know why
people get married if they're not
intending to you know right but have a
better purpose but I'm saying from like
a guy's point of view why would you sign
a contract that she's paid to leave when
the divorce rate is 50 like what
incentive does he have
well uh what's the purpose of you
getting married if that's what you're
worried about
and if you're dating the kind of girls
that are going to do that then you need
to find a better dating pool
um
you see you think it's all on the on the
men
and the women there no it's on both
that's what I'm saying like normal women
that you wouldn't expect still leave
their husbands
so it's like why would a guy sign a
contract where she's paid to leave
that comes down to trust like with my
wife who when we got married about six
years ago like when we got married it
was to create a stable foundation for
our family she could right now I'm in
the place where there's a no-fault
divorce she could at any time leave me
but at the same time like we both have
expectations of each other like I have
expectations for her she has
expectations for me we have to live up
to it and uh one time we were joking uh
when we were engaged we're walking in a
river valley here and we ran into this
old couple and they told us they've been
married 60 years and my wife asked like
hey did you guys ever like think of
divorce or anything and the old lady
just looked at her she's like divorced
she's like never honey murder a few
times yeah
oh and and I agree with you like I think
that's the ideal but again I just think
right now the laws are the way they are
and is it wise to tell men to sign that
contract with the laws being the way
they are
like I I just personally like have a
hard time encouraging that because again
like men are more likely to commit
suicide after a divorce they could lose
access to their children they could lose
half of their everything they've worked
20 30 years to build up and it's if you
get on a plane and there's a 50 chance
of you
of it crashing are you likely to get on
the plane probably not and like I I
understand like there's different
um in the Mormon Community I'm sure this
isn't as prevalent but it this most
people don't live in that community
and so what is the average guy supposed
to do
oh 100 agree like I said the culture is
completely messed up nowadays outside
like I didn't realize how messed up it'd
become until I started watching your
shows and seeing yeah with the people
you bring off the street actually say
and it just blew my mind yeah but um I
think I think probably
yeah
what's the real solution going forward
me and my wife we're open about talking
about this stuff and like for example
like I we've talked about one time like
the number one thing that triggers
divorce is the guy losing his job
and it's not that my wife would ever
want to like ditch me just because I
lose my job I mean I make a healthy
income she's able to be a stay-at-home
mom but at the same time I know that if
the income stops coming in her
uncertainty is going to go through the
roof and she's going to eventually just
be her own biology is going to force her
to leave
so and on the flip side you know I I
tell her you know like
I gotta sometimes I'm a little horny and
I want to have sex sometimes and she
understands that and then at the same
time I tell her hey I'm out making the
money you can help my certainty a ton by
taking care of the home making sure the
place is nice doing the classic like
being a home mother kind of situation so
when I come home I'm able I don't come
home to more chaos in my life no and I
agree that and of course we help each
other out no and I I agree that's how it
should be but my question still is what
is the solution moving forward you you
would still say that men should sign a
contract that women are paid to leave
because again like it's it's nice to say
oh in an ideal situation this is how it
should be but we're in modern times
but I'm also a modern times and I like
LDS culture and it's not just LDS but
also like
more Orthodox Christian and uh other
religious groups we still live in the
culture where marriage is a big deal and
it's culturally enforced
so my best advice to men would be to go
and go into a culture where marriage is
valued there's still pockets of it out
there everywhere uh it's not mainstream
you're going to be going into a pool
where there's women and men who have
expectations and you have expectations
so my best advice to guys would be to go
enter into one of those cultures where
there's still that pressure from her
family from your family from the people
in your community to maintain marriage
as what it should be as opposed to going
in out and dating people in a place
where that's not
you know there's no cultural pressure to
stay together because then you're trying
to rely on legal pressure and you know
you see how far that goes
yeah I just I don't know it doesn't
really sit right with me to tell guys to
sign a contract that women are paid to
leave and trust that she won't
and go just go to somewhere where her
friends and her family will tell her not
to
you know
yeah you know I can see
I can honestly tell you if you're
looking at it from a pure legal
standpoint and the only thing that's
forcing you two to stay together is a
legal contract that's easily broken and
there's no point do you need more than
just a legal contract there isn't as
many of
many of you talk
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible